In the last few weeks, my face is very red, is this rosacea?
What is the reason is it connected to gut health?
Well, certainly, you could Google pictures on rosacea and see if
if your redness looks like a rosacea ranch.
But if you can look at those Google pictures of rosacea, it goes,
oh my gosh, that's exactly what it looks like.
Then you know that it's H. Pylora.
So H. Pylora is the cause of rosacea.
There could be other reasons for a red face.
That isn't H. Pylora because it isn't rosacea.
So getting a proper diagnosis would be in order.
So if you don't feel comfortable going to Google and looking at pictures,
then getting into a practitioner that could identify rosacea, maybe,
or dermatologist would be in order.
But if it is rosacea, then it is H. Pylora.
Is that a gut issue?
Well, yes and no.
I mean, H. Pylora starts and they got,
but it doesn't necessarily stay in the gut.
Again, that's the problem with doing a test for H. Pylora.
You got, you know, three main ways to test for H. Pylora.
You could do the urea-brett test.
That will be positive if you have H. Pylora elevated in the stomach.
Maybe in the first part of the first part of the duanda.
But if it's not elevated in the stomach anymore,
and it's elevated in the intestinal tract,
then a stool sample tested for H. Pylora, which are positive.
If it's not elevated in the stomach anymore,
not elevated in the intestinal tract,
then the urea-brett test and the stool sample, maybe, negative.
The other test is the anti-body test.
The test is kind of useless because that will be elevated.
That's, that's typically just an IgG test.
I don't think they have an IgN test for H. Pylora.
I haven't seen that. Maybe they do now.
So that's just going to test past exposure.
It doesn't super high elevated enough to give you clues of courage exposure.
So you have to look at other factors as well.
So you had a history of H. Pylora.
Then the knowledge that the fact that it could very well and very,
most commonly can, will go systemic in effect.
Other parts of the body, the skin is very common.
It's rosacea, cause by H. Pylora,
but you can look cause other skin rushes.
And it was a weird rash all the way down just their left arm.
It was a weird case.
I didn't know what it was when I looked at it.
Certainly looked anything like rosacea.
They didn't have it.
And for all other decorative face.
Tested them and it was rosacea.
And it was that rosacea.
It was H. Pylora.
And we treated for H. Pylora.
Literally the rash went away in a few days.
And it was a good boy going on.
Kytos, burberry and garlic.
The things that you would do for H. Pylora.
But if you have a systemic H. Pylora,
then you just have to assume that it's affecting your endothelial cells.
And that's the worst case scenario.
So, I mean, of course, worst case scenario would be H. Pylora.
Cancer, but H. Pylora does cause cancer.
It's a common cause of prostate cancer and other cancers as well.
But it is one of the most common cause of endothelial disorder.
So, causing damage and inflammation to the lining of your arteries.
And of course, you know, we all want to get rid of cancer.
But we don't want to die of heart disease while we're waiting to try to get rid of cancer.
I'm from the firm belief that everybody should treat themselves
as if they have H. Pylora.
At least in a pulse that the lady that I'll take.
Our.
Para.
Clear, which is a great H. Pylora killer because it's got.
I think I didn't know which here right away.
That's because I think it's got different parasite things like.
Like a regular regular was actually good for H. Pylora where would.
A clove garlic is really good clove is really good for liver parasites liver flakes.
Garlic powder, which is really good for all parasites.
Good for cancer.
Good for your heart.
Add good for.
Chili and H. Pylora.
And it's got slippery elm bark, which is really good to help heal your gut.
It's got a casseroid, which is good for your gut.
Violet golden seal, which is good for H. Pylora.
Great food seed extract, which is good for H. Pylora.
Also good for multiple other parasites.
Barberry root, which is good for H. Pylora in a source of burberry.
So I take that.
Not daily, but regularly.
And I also take burberry.
Very regularly.
So longer my favorite things.
For H. Pylora.
I think everybody should be knowledgeable about H. Pylora.
That's why I tell people to read.
The blog post.
He'll go back to Pylora and things to do to deal with it.
And follow those steps.
I think everybody needs to address that.
Whether you have cancer or not.
Because it is just so prevalent.
And I don't want you as a cancer patient to have a heart attack.
It's, you know, it's easy to be model minded.
Single minded, but our focus of treated cancer.
And we have other cool morbidities that could.
You know, cause us, you know, help.
So we have to be reminded about that.